film courage calm courage yes ok tarsem
perfect perfect good Indian guidance how
did you get the job to direct selfless
how did it all happen I told the agents
for a while that I'm not going to do
another let's say for lack of a better
word fantastical movie and I'd said that
and then the next one happened the next
one then sunny ended up with four and
that's all I was getting there and just
said ok let's break it up I need to do a
trailer if not just two people talking
in a room dinner with Andre style so I
just said I need to do that otherwise
because it's what interests me a lot and
I'm not seeing it so this was something
that came across my way and I just said
it's a perfect piece it answers a lot of
questions that I think are coming out
soon and it's it's basically you know in
in a Trojan way put into a thriller I'll
go for them the first five things you do
once you get on set as a director first
first day of production uh I would say
there I wouldn't even say the things
that you remember probably just in the
morning get up take a piss brush your
teeth it's it's as generic is that and
for me just remember the first day of
shoot is not the first day of the movie
like most people perceive it to be it's
usually somebody sitting with the
clothes up opening a drawer because the
actor isn't coming out of the Sun is not
going down that thing so you think
you're gonna shoot the scene you end up
shooting some close-ups so you actually
just flow into it so there isn't a for
me you know come to Jesus meeting there
isn't it just is let's make this thing
yeah okay and everybody just you come
out and you boat okay do you remember
the first production where you acted as
a director yes
an actual paying job and you don't have
to mention it uh-huh
the lesson you learned could be good or
bad uh yes just because I just come out
from school and I just thought you know
what everything out here I'd never had a
dolly I never had a crane I just kept
using all of them and then suddenly
hobbits who I realized what we were
shooting was crap and then I went to the
band and I just said I think you guys
are very different than what I've been
shooting right now I can throw it all
away
and give what you want because I just
saw the main lead he's not feeling well
after shooting for almost a full day or
in the two day shoe he was dancing it
was my
style and losing origin I just said you
know what I didn't throw everything else
out can we do this they said we have no
idea what you're doing because you never
wrote a treatment do what you want and I
just said great
so just went into it and changed
everything so the lesson was spontaneity
yes means like no adapt think on your
feet because for me I think I should
have a V girlfriend I had in school she
was brilliant in composing shots making
everybody's wardrobe was perfect this
one she was always doing this and when
we separated I remember I was going on
and on and on and on talking about how
this girl was everything and then you
know like had everything down correctly
and then I met Fincher and he told me
you and I both know that you know like
filmmaking is not about coming up with
the perfect shot in a blog really I
thought that's what it was but he
thought he said no it's about getting
thinking it takes five shots to shoot a
scene Suns going down the actors not
coming out this thing not happening the
weather went back you take three shots
to tell the same story and I just
realized I was so much got to do with
adaption and it wasn't my initial step
and I did the commercials at all it was
my way or no I'm leaving my vase I was
the spoiled kid for about five six years
because I was learning the tools after
that time when I started working with
people who are higher up on the food
chain than you actors you go up there
and then suddenly they change things
that you just go if I don't dance and
adapt right now what I had on the board
not going to work
you